[Music]
john
is with us in philadelphia hi john
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave can you hear me sure what's up
hey uh
kind of a simple question for you today
um i'm 22 i have no credit
um i was wondering if it was good as a
beginner to get a small amount of credit
say 300 bucks or so uh with unsecured
debt for
credit worthiness i guess if that's so
you want to be worthy to borrow money
and go in debt
yes no just kidding well that's credit
worthiness right
okay well i didn't know because my dad
always told me
is an important thing and then i started
watching your show a couple months back
and i'm starting to realize maybe he's
not maybe it's not such an important
thing you know so
but john not only you're 22 and you
don't have any why don't you have it
i don't know i just never started well
that's a blessing in disguise my friend
yes all right that's wonderful glad to
hear that so here's the thing
the you're right the culture including
your dad
everybody says you need credit because
everybody has been told by the banking
industry for
75 years that the best way to become
prosperous is
borrow to buy the stuff you want
right and so it's been culturally
accepted that that's the way to go
however that's a bill of goods sold to
us
by a villain known as the bank
because it built large towers in our
skylines and they all have bank names on
them
it didn't build a large tower in your
living room
because all your living room money from
your dad went to that bank
and so the borrower's slave to the
lender is a very real thing
and what we have discovered is the
shortest
least risk path to wealth
is to not have any payments
and then the question always comes up
well don't i need to get some payments
so that i have credit why so that i can
get some payments
so that i have credit why so that i can
get some payments
so that i have credit and debt why
and so the point being that we
tell folks to um you know stay out of
debt because
it's the shortest path to wealth that's
what it comes down to
and you already discovered that watching
our videos right
yeah okay and i understand it's
counter-cultural
but if you look around the culture most
people are broke exactly yeah
and john let me let you in on this um i
worked in the industry the banking world
for about 12 years
and didn't understand really the fico
score until i joined dave's team
and the fico score measures how much
debt you have
the type of debt you have the likelihood
that they'll give you more debt and how
you've paid debt
there's a theme there and that it's not
a matter of how wealthy you are or how
well you're doing
it's how you're doing with debt so no
sir you don't need to bring on any debt
in your life
i love the fact that you've avoided it
at 22
and want to continue to encourage you to
avoid it like the plague
like the plague there is nothing
positive that's going to come from it
and i promise you your mailbox is going
to start to get some offers
you're going to start to see it and be
more aware of it and i want you to have
that mindset ready
because as soon as you let your guard
down that's when stupid will creep in
yeah stupid will sneak up on you yes